today in the case of DC versus Heller
the Supreme Court for the very first
time in US history
authoritative Lee declared that the
Second Amendment to the Constitution
does indeed protect an individual right
to own weapons for self-defense in the
home that right is not necessarily
connected to membership in any kind of
organized militia gun control forces of
for decades been arguing that it is not
an individual right the Supreme Court
has now declared that it is
this decision was a very important
victory in the long-lasting war over gun
control and gun rights but it is by no
means the end of the war the Supreme
Court made a valuable and desirable but
very limited decision in in DC v Heller
the the laws that were being challenged
in this case were the worst most
draconian anti gun laws that this
country has ever known in in DC since
the 1976 it has been completely illegal
to have a handgun of any sort and while
it's been legal to have a rifle or a
shotgun you had to keep them
disassembled and/or unloaded in trigger
locked which meant it was never illegal
to have a functioning weapon in your
home for self defense the Supreme Court
has said that that will not fly that
kind of law is not legitimate under the
Second Amendment however there are all
sorts of other gun control regulations
that will continue to be legitimate some
of which the court actually listed in in
their decision including
laws regulating concealed carry laws
regulating the type of people who are
permitted to own guns for example a
felons are not legally allowed to own
guns that's still okay under their
decision
people have been institutionalized
that's still okay so they have not gone
ahead and said authoritative ly what
sort of gun control regulations might be
vulnerable under their decision except
that a complete ban is now off the table
gun control groups interestingly enough
have been trying to spin the Heller
decision as a victory of sorts for them
and their thinking is pretty interesting
they're maintaining that for four
decades the gun rights Lobby the NRA and
other groups of that sort have made
their bread and butter on this fear that
someday a federal agent is going to come
knocking on your door trying to take
your guns away and that gun rights
people have seen every single gun
regulation as just a step on that
slippery slope toward a total ban toward
total confiscation what the hell're
decision is done it's taken the ban
issue off the table the Supreme Court
has said that states localities the
federal government might be legally able
to regulate gun ownership in many many
ways but one thing they cannot do is
completely ban having the use of guns in
your home so with that issue off the
table there's still an enormous amount
of room for challenges to all sorts of
gun regulations from concealed carry
regulations from regulations affecting
gun dealers and we are definitely going
to see tons and tons more lawsuits about
gun regulations down the line this is by
no means the end of the public policy
fight over gun control it by no means
the end of the legal fight over gun
control like with most major Supreme
Court decisions this is going to be the
beginning of decades of more lawsuits
decades and more legal decisions decades
more debates in in you know state houses
City Council's across the country but
the guidance that the Supreme Court is
given today is that we do need to
remember that we do as Americans have
the right to self-defense and that guns
weapons is as unpleasant as many people
find them are are often essential tools
toward that self-defense and
self-defense is a right not created by
the Second Amendment it's a right we
have inherently as human beings and it's
a right that's protected by the Second
Amendment and that's a very important
victory for for the cause of gun rights
and human rights in America
for many many decades every single
federal appeals court except one the
Fifth Circuit has fallen into this
pretty unsupportable view that there is
no individual right to own weapons that
because the word militia is in is in the
Second Amendment that it only applies to
membership in a militia there was never
any good reason to believe this and if
you read Justice Scalia's opinion he
really tears it apart piece by piece in
a very entertaining way sometimes having
to say things that you're amazed that
they had to be said in a Supreme Court
opinion for example that the word keep
as in keep arms means that someone can
actually keep a gun in their home
strangely enough lots of very bright
legal minds have have argued otherwise
for decades and a Scalia finally slapped
that nonsense down so yeah the
establishment that there is an
individual right even though that right
may be regulatable in many ways that
were only going to figure out with
future court decisions is a very good
base from which to start and if the
decision had come down the other way and
it was a 5-4 decision it would very
easily could have that would be the end
basically any the end for gun rights
basically any locality anywhere could
completely eliminate our ability to
defend ourselves in the best way
possible so absolutely a very good and a
vitally important decision but not at
all the final word in the fight over a
gun gun regulation